as 2020 comes to a close netflix is
finishing out the year with a brand new
assortment of television shows
original films beloved classics
documentaries and
more to keep you entertained and
occupied here are all the best movies
and tv shows coming to netflix in
december
2020 right at the beginning of the month
mank the newest film from acclaimed
director david fincher
arrives on december 4th mank tells the
story of famed screenwriter hermann j
mankowitz played by gary oldman as he
writes the classic drama film citizen
kane
it also details mankowitz's personal
battles with director orson welles as
citizen kane was in production
and up to his theatrical debut in 1941.
what is it the writer says tell the
story you know
with a supporting cast that includes
amanda seyfried lily collins
charles dance and more as well as a new
original score from frequent fincher
collaborators
trent reznor and atticus ross there's no
doubt that manc will be a movie to watch
as awards season begins
on december 11th musical theater fans
will be able to stream ryan murphy's to
prom
adapted from the award-winning broadway
musical of the same name
featuring megawatt stars like meryl
streep james corden
and nicole kidman the prom centers
around broadway actors longing for the
illustrious days of their past who
journey to a small indiana town
to help a high school student be allowed
to take her girlfriend to prom
a few days later on december 18th
chadwick boseman's final film will
arrive on netflix
the world was stunned in august 2020
when the black panther star passed away
from stage four colon cancer
and his final performance will come in
ma rainey's black bottom
the true story of a music legend and one
difficult day in the recording studio
the film stars viola davies as mahrani
an iconic blue singer
and boseman co-stars as the aspirational
and determined trumpeter
levy finally just before christmas
george clooney's post-apocalyptic
thriller the midnight sky will hit
netflix on december 23rd
it tells the tale of a scientist in the
arctic who's racing against time to stop
a group of astronauts from returning
home to a global disaster
if you're holed up with your family this
christmas and looking for a new series
to binge
netflix has no shortage of exciting
options netflix will kick off the month
with a continuation of its series the
movies that made us
but this time it has a festive twist
holiday movies that made us will hit the
service on december 1st
shortly thereafter the anticipated
fourth season of nick kroll's hit
animated series big mouth will arrive on
december 4th
followed by the premiere of selena the
series which tells the story of the
tajano singer's life before a former
friend killed her in 1995
when selena was just 23 years old if
you're a fan of thrillers you'll want to
check out the mess you leave behind
created by elite writer carlos montero
the series hits netflix on december 11th
on the flip side if you're a music fan
looking for light affair you won't want
to miss the second series of song
exploder
which interviews singer-songwriters like
lin-manuel miranda
and alicia keys and is based on the
podcasts of the same name
song exploder arrives on december 15th
on christmas day
netflix subscribers will get the best
gift of all bridgeton
the first product of showrunner shonda
rhimes huge deal with the streaming
service
narrated by dame julie andrews that's
the gossip monger lady whistle down
bridgeton follows the ins and outs of
high society in london
and is sure to draw in fans of rhymes
previous fair like scandal
and grey's anatomy my name is lady
whistle down you do not know me
and never shall finally on december 31st
just before 2020 comes to an end you can
stream the fourth and final season
of the kianan shipka starring series
chilling adventures of sabrina
aside from new original films netflix is
adding a ton of beloved classics in
december 2020
if you're a fan of quirky romantic
comedies you'll definitely want to check
out 50 first dates
which stars frequent collaborators drew
barrymore and adam sandler as a couple
facing a unique relationship hurdle
50 first dates will be available to
stream beginning on december 1st
if you want to relive your childhood
with some of spielberg's best films
et the extraterrestrial jurassic park
and jurassic park 3 will be available on
netflix as well
all hitting the streamer on the first of
the month dan brown enthusiasts will be
happy to hear that both of the authors
tom hanks led adaptations the da vinci
code
and angels and demons will hit netflix
in december 2020.
meanwhile if you loved john favreau and
roy choi's chef show
you'll want to check out favreau's film
chef which built the friendship between
choi and the director
all of the above hit netflix on december
1st after that the acclaimed films
nocturnal animals and lee daniels to
butler
arrive on netflix in the middle of the
month on december 16th and just as
december draws to a close you can
revisit the animated flick rango
which arrives on december 28th next
month you can tuck into everything from
a massive reality tv show marathon
to a much beloved sci-fi series that's
been around forever
on december 1st seasons 1 and 2 of the
dating show are you the one
and seasons one and two of tattoo
competition ink masters
will join netflix two weeks later on
december 15th the first two seasons of
black ink crew new york about
a tattoo shop in harlem and seasons one
and two of teen mom 2
join the frey a couple of seasons of
mtv's to challenge
seasons 10 and 13 specifically will
arrive that same day
if you're looking for a gritty new drama
to binge and want to expand your
horizons beyond the united states
you'll definitely want to check out
season 1 of kings of joburg
a south african drama about the crime
world of johannesburg that arrives on
netflix on december 4th and if a tried
and true series is what you're after
this december
set aside some time to watch 10 seasons
of stargate sg1
which hits the platform on the first of
the month and those still reeling from
the death of jeopardy host alex trebek
who passed away on november 8
2020 after battling cancer can revisit
some of trebek's best moments on
december 18th
when a slew of jeopardy challenge runs
and tournaments will arrive on netflix
if you're a fan of hard-hitting
documentaries and or gut-busting
stand-up specials
you're in for a treat on netflix in
december 2020
those who can't get enough of medical
fare like er and house will definitely
love the surgeon's cuts
which follows real life surgical
pioneers as they discover new medical
breakthroughs the dark u series hits the
service on december 9th
in search of something more uplifting
try out giving voice arriving to netflix
on december 11th
it tells the true story of the annual
august wilson monologue competition
which allows lucky young winners to
perform original works on broadway
true crime buffs however will want to
free up their schedules on december 16th
as that's when the ripper drops on
netflix the documentary follows
real-life witnesses and investigators
as they recall how the yorkshire ripper
described as a modern-day jack the
ripper
tormented northern england in the late
70s meanwhile netflix will also give a
voice to some fresh new faces and
stand-up comedy
on december 1st natalie palomides will
make her netflix debut with nate a
one-man show where she uses an alter ego
for a stand-up
the very next day on december 2nd ariel
john and hazel brugger
also step into the world of netflix
original specials with the premieres of
their respective specials
pardon my icelandic and tropical and
finally if you're looking to celebrate
new year z with some laughs
load up netflix's best stand-up of 2020
a compilation of the funniest jokes from
comedians in the us
canada australia and new zealand that
have launched specials in 2020
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
what to watch on your favorite streaming
platforms
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one